now king is not your real last name is
that right what what is your real last
name
zeiger i was born with the name lawrence
harvey zeiger z-e-i-g-e-r and i got the
name king in a funny way my first day on
the radio
all my life i've dreamed of being on the
radio it was my
i never wanted to be anything else but a
broadcaster
and finally i got hired a small station
in miami beach finally my dreams come
true
and i get a job i'm going to start
monday morning as a disc jockey and all
weekend i'm nervous and i'm practicing
and i'm
it's quarter nine small radio station
general manager calls me and he says
well you're ready i said i'm ready
he says this is your big day you're
starting radio i'm 22 years old
yes he says what name you're going to
use and he says larry zeiger he said you
can't use that
i said well i said well it's ethnic
people won't know how to spell it they
won't remember it
i said well what i'm nervous enough
and he had the miami herald open it was
an ad for king's wholesale liquors
and he said wait a minute that's what
the ad was king's hotel liquors
1925 walton road he says uh why don't
you take larry king
so you're named after a sale on booze
i am named after a vast liquor sale wow
you could have been larry wholesale
literally i know that could have been
see it could have been a lot worse he's
right he could have been a lot worse
andy you know i love you i know
i love you too
and you know
you know why your career hasn't
bounced forward because you would have
named the guy
larry's husband larry
and i tell you and that would have been
funny for a week
there's about there but there would
never be there were no shut-ins that
would have made me the here or their
hero
but there never would have been a
larry's wholesale liquor live 10th
anniversary
i should probably explain to the people
at home uh you know these two have had a
bit of a running feud going whenever
they come on the show there's a bit of a
few i don't know what it is
it's something about him it's a bit of a
feud between these two no
he's funny yeah but you know something
larry it it it looks
funny it got a little ugly last time i
don't know if you remember this but uh i
think we should show it again can we
show this clip please dana i thought it
got a little ugly last time maybe i'm
crazy
a clip of that time with andy please i
got a great idea we're gonna do a show
okay i'm gonna have both of you on
together oh that'd be nice and we'll
talk to a star
and a sidekick okay star
sidekick okay this show is a step up
right yeah
yeah so i come in i meet a neanderthal
proud of it he's proud of it you don't
really need him no
you are a star what exactly does he do
you want to know what i do this is what
i do
i mean i know that looked like fun that
looked like fun to you people that got
us into so much trouble with cnn you
were
it was hours getting your head back on
we had to beg you to come back
beg me that's still not right i just
think
still i still get a little quirk i think
we should take a break right now i think
you two
should just uh cement this thing once
and for all i'll come back one more with
larry king we'll see in a second